we're going to get to Matthew Perry now
and his first sit down since his new
bombshell book
I was
a coma and you know escaped
death really narrowly Secrets kill you
Secrets kill people like me I was in a
dark room meeting with nothing but
drug dealers and completely alone the 53
year old reveals he spent about nine
million dollars trying to get sober and
in a New York Times article called the
one where Matthew Perry writes an
addiction Memoir the actor drops a sad
bombshell about his wedding on friends I
love you after Monica and Chandler's
wedding in the season seven finale
Matthew says he was driven back to the
treatment center where he was staying in
a pickup truck helmed by a sober
technician another surprise Matthew
dumped Julia Roberts why don't you call
me in 20 years and tell me if you're
still upset about this in his new Memoir
friends lovers and the big terrible
thing Matthew writes that just two
months into their romance he ended
things due to his own insecurities quote
I had been constantly certain that she
was going to break up with me why would
she not I was not enough I could never
be enough I was broken bent unlovable
you're on methadone Xanax full quarter
vodka day
55 Viking on a day 50 55
. yeah Matt who says he recently
celebrated 18 months of sobriety also
sits down with Diane Sawyer for an ABC
news interview airing Friday Night
Jennifer
and she says we know you're drinking
yeah imagine how scary moment that was
she was the one that reached out the
most and you know are really grateful to
her for that